alors le chemin de compostelle reprend
le chemin de saint martin le paysage de
saint martin et est antérieure au chemin
de compostelle et
donc l'association a repris ce chemin
qui est souvent d'ailleurs un chemin de
grande randonnée est ce que c'était un
chemin qui étaient utilisés par les
pèlerins ou est ce que vous l'avez
finalement un peu improvisé alors il y a
des étapes qui était qui existait déjà
qu'ils étaient utilisés par les pèlerins
et où nous avons fait des raccordements
pour aller jusqu'à tours alors en fait
les personnes qui veulent nous rejoindre
ils vont quoi ils vont sur site ce sont
pas forcément des croyants en plus
absolument
bon il existe un site qu'on possède 41
on peut avoir toute une information
alors vous évoquez est ce que les
pèlerins sont croyants non je pense que
les la plupart des pèlerins au départ
sont les gens qui se cherche qui
s'interrogent sur leur histoire leur
devenir
mais quand il arrive à compostelle après
pratiquement deux mois de marche
je pense qu'ils ont fait une démarche
aussi spirituelle initiatique et donc
ensuite ils reviennent ils ont changé et
sont métamorphosés oui
j'ai tellement les gens reviennent plus
tolérants avec une solidarité importante
est le plus souvent ils repartent ils
repartent pour sur un autre chemin de
compostelle